on this episode we talk Chamber of
Commerce we talk at wine deals the
greatest place to buy wine on Instagram
and when is the right time to have an
assistant
[Music]
Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is it was sub 135
of the ask gary vee show this is
wonderful to be back in the main saddle
after a wonderful three weeks of
spending an enormous amount of time with
the kids
tremendous just a ton of kids time got
to spend a good amount of time really
putting a lot of meat on the askgaryvee
the book which was nice feels like
that's always a burden on my head these
damn books so that was good to get done
just really connected with the family
got really zoned in on the New York Jets
season have my preview show of the
upcoming season on Friday look for that
and and just been missing you guys at
the Manor nation got to interact with
you guys a little bit on Instagram and
so that was good but now we're back in
full swing and and that's that so India
let and he is on vacation stunwin would
facial hair well stun when let's get
into the show nope no chance that's
Indian eyes thing fine Gregory asked if
you ever become to see all of a local
chamber of a community of 12,000 what
would be the first thing you would do if
I became the CEO of the Chamber of
Commerce for a small group of 12,000
people
12,000 members or 12,000 people in a
town a command you know that I'm a very
big fan of scaling the unscalable right
I talk a lot about engagement one-on-one
engagement Twitter videos depth versus
width when when you're talking about a
town of 12,000 people even if we're
answering this incorrectly and it's a
membership of 12,000 it's still a very
small number in this even thing so what
I would 'mentally do is create a
infrastructure to allow me to connect
one by
with every single member of the chamber
and even considering if it's a 12,000
person community the thousand to four
thousand people that really care about
business in town and connect with them
one by one
via coffee via Skype via phone call as
much face-to-face as possible
and ask them to reverse engineer their
objectives of meaning what can the
chamber do for you what do you want out
of it I'd also have a better
understanding of what I was trying to
get out of it if I was the CEO of that
so I don't know if that's fees I don't
know if it's something as simply noble
as making business better in town if
that's the objective half that's a
little bit of a ton of tongue-in-cheek
for the people that don't get my humor
and this I think I get razzed a little
bit too much for this as I was reading
plenty of comments on these three weeks
I basically my job would be to make the
business environment in this community
better and I think the number one way to
do that is to get people aligned I think
leadership comes from getting an entire
group of people aligned on a mission I
actually think the most effective way to
do that is to actually understand each
individual's person's goals and
objectives and then come and find that
little sweet spot that is the closest
thing to the overall masses that brings
value across the board and then go
backwards what's the number one thing
that I can do that brings value to all
600 people at vaynermedia that brings
value to all 12,000 members and then go
down the list to where the number 10
thing maybe brings value to half of the
people but it's still better than to
three people so I reverse engineer by
listening upfront collecting the data
and then executing against the top ten
things that will bring value to
everybody in the organization sweet
buyer off the game it's can I get the
kind of fire emoji
little editing for you rock
Sam asks what is one of your favorite
questions asked by an interviewee for a
position at vaynermedia I don't like
when interviewees talk what is my
favorite question by the way it's there
was a little bit of a truth in that
statement it's something I've been
giving a lot of thought to is is I'm
live you got something No OHA break some
news I see you're happy too so it's not
the Jets are in big trouble again is
that spiky oh my god what
so three aspects that came out of the
report one a owner confidentially told
outside the lines that he thought the
flake gate was a make up call for spike
it makes sense owners are probably
generally happy with how Goodell handled
it even though he lost yep
outside the lines is reporting not can't
be completely based in fact that they
think Spygate was 40 games worth of tape
at least Wow
and there was one other fact Mike Martz
former coach of the Rams yes on the
record as saying that he put out a
statement saying he was satisfied with
the investigation
but that Goodell called him and asked
him to do it and marks is now on the
record without sideline saying that he
believes Spygate was really bad and that
they lost the Super Bowl because of it
he didn't say that
but he I'm saying but he's saying gödel
asked him to put out the same man he
didn't belong even that he put out a lot
of outside Alliance huge story explain I
love it we hate the Patriots around here
just the bottom line
Wow it's good I kind of questioned about
deflategate room you know what is that
right dude that being said I do want to
say the following I'm not upset about
the Tom Brady ruling a lot of you asked
me I'm happy that he's playing I'm happy
all right I'm serious by way I'd rather
him play we don't play them in those for
those interviewee Oh in urdu ii yeah you
know the truth is I don't have a really
great answer for this I like when
interviewees ask me honest questions I
think a lot of times they're just
in they went to some website and that
says seven best questions to ask for in
an interview or they had an interview
coach or their dad told them to say
something
I hate mailed in [ __ ] I like when
they and or when they pander to me like
Gary what are you gonna do when you buy
the Jets or that like I don't need that
either though I like it I like being
coddled I don't need it
we're there to try to help them help me
help us help them as a team and the
truth is what I'm looking for so you
know not that they have to go the other
way and ask me a hard-hitting question
either I don't care if it's if they
truly want to know what I'm gonna do
when I buy the Jets then I'm happy if
they truly want to ask me like is the
vulnerability of this company your
charisma and personal brand and what
happens without you if they truly mean
it and they're not just trying to win
points on asking the hard-hitting
question you know I think that that has
always been my thing I don't want
anybody going too far in either
direction of [ __ ]
just keep it in the lane of something
that really matters to you and so
sometimes I like you know now it's
spurring up summers sometimes I like
when they ask about like how much can
they contribute to the 401k or or do you
really truly allow unlimited vacation
time like like I like what it's just
actually coming from something they want
to know for themselves I feel like I'm
there to provide value to them I don't
think an interviewee is trying to sell
me on them to work for me
I think I'm trying to sell them I'm
working for me and so I really flip
interviews on their head that way and
that's an interesting thing altogether
maybe I just love selling so much maybe
I'm trying from the day we meet create
an environment of safety which I'm very
proud of that I think I create here
that's the answer in your paw I like
been your pop I gary vaynerchuck on
holidays here but I've got a question
for you what have you learned from wine
deals your Instagram account the best
place to buy wine in America link me up
here what have you learnt from your wine
deals Instagram account that small
wineries can still use to make a buck on
Instagram Cheers good job in your paw
oh that was hot loop yeah that's cool
does it whoop yeah yeah I'm desktop yeah
very Paul great question I've learned
what I thought with creating wine deals
the greatest place on Instagram to buy
wine which is people are
disproportionally paying attention to
Instagram Plus Instagram has built-in
word-of-mouth functionality people by
habit when they see something on
Instagram that they think somebody else
is gonna be interested in tagged their
friends in the comments they leave a
comment with that person's user handle
because everybody's paying attention to
Instagram they're seeing that alert then
they are then checking it out I have not
seen anything work like this since early
email early and too early Twitter I'm
sorry this is very early email very
early Twitter where anybody who's on the
platform is disproportionately paying
attention to the platform in a way that
creates aggressive word-of-mouth
infrastructure so we're selling a lot of
wine we haven't even taken it that
serious Steve you're about to get really
really in there you know we're kind of
in the summer months which is fun but
now here we are you know as I start
seeing you know it's funny when I start
seeing leaves go orange and you know and
all that stuff like that's when I know
it's time for money right because I came
from retail and the fourth quarter is
what I mean literally this day I'm gonna
go literally get goosebumps this exact
day for me the day I stopped going to
school was the greatest day of my life
because it was the day that [ __ ] was
about to get serious at Wine Library
because we were about to view a lot of
sales in these next 16 to 20 weeks and
football and no school I mean just like
the best so as much as I love running
vaynermedia and as much as this is gonna
be a much bigger company as much as this
is awesome I'm still a merchants at
heart and I as I'm fired up to you know
here today and ready to go but I can't
lie a little extra kicker because I love
selling stuff and and me and Brant even
last night I'm like with Brandon I'm
like here we go like I'm so pumped for
this Saturday I had an interesting
Instagram post a couple
ago about this upcoming Saturday in the
store I've got surprise gifts for people
they're going to see brand I won't be
there don't want to fool anybody and so
and so uh vendor Paul I think I think
that people's attention is on this
platform and that you need to be
storytelling on it and I do think it's a
tremendous direct response selling right
hook platform and wine deals as many of
you guys know is straight right hooks
it's three wine offers at discount
prices and by the end like there's no
thrills it's you know clever Instagram
like pictures to the best of our ability
and and but it's the wine and so the
attention rap is real people's
word-of-mouth infrastructures real and
we're picking up a lot of customers
that's going well Jordan asked what is
your biggest goal heading into the
homestretch of 2015 my biggest goal
professionally is where I'm gonna go
with this is to set up vaynermedia for
its biggest year I get all my denture
capital and investing world in order a
lot of transition a lot of exciting
stuff coming that you'll be hearing
about wrap up wrap up the book very much
focus on resi and brave and faith box
the businesses that I'm and grape story
the businesses that I'm deeper involved
with get deeper into the HR of a hundred
employees of vaynermedia that I haven't
gone as far with and have that personal
connection with dismantle the askgaryvee
show through the winter and put out
better and better better content work
closely with the rock to to make a
couple of killer original videos work
with you Steve to make wine deals really
powerful and I think we can so those are
some of the things off the time I have
hopefully have my first really exciting
football season in five years forty
years I really am very optimistic or
maybe not you'll find out Friday on my
football Premiership and and start the
process and most of all number one now
put a little personal in there continue
the workout regimen I don't know if you
noticed but I'm starting to go into
muscle gaining mode and
and start the process of hacking more
time with the kids from a Monday through
Friday standpoint than I have whether
that's walking to school whether that's
coming home early it's not built into
the infrastructure of September the way
I wanted it to me maybe because I've got
so much time in August that it didn't
populate but um I'm definitely in the
same way that if this show was going on
the year before I started working out I
know it started right when I started
working out you would have heard me talk
a lot about working out working out
working out I'm a very smoke then fire
kind of individual so I'm starting the
smoke on this on this kids hack thing
because the extremes are working but I'm
trying to find a little more time Tim
asks when do you know it's time to hire
an assistant Tim asks when do you know
it's time to hire an assistant should we
title by the way what's that show titled
yeah this is a great show title let's go
with that Dirac uh you know for me was
Matt cinema who worked in the order
department at Wine Library who is now a
lead account strategist in our LA office
who's the only employee I took from Wine
Library to vaynermedia when we started
it I have enormous heart for him he's
also battling Brandon my best friend who
runs Wine Library for the championship
and our fantasy baseball league this
year so it's Brandon versus madam
watching that very carefully for these
next 30 days enjoying that so but for me
it was that I started to have to be
places and I wasn't completely in charge
or had all the leverage what I mean by
that is when I ran Wine Library and I
was literally in the store 12 hours a
day every day
I didn't schedule a lot of things and if
I did I went off memory and if they
showed up and I screwed up and that made
them wait an hour I was okay with that
even though that was disrespectful of
someone else's time I was the biggest
wine buyer that they had and they were
there to sell me and I was ok with that
when I started having to show up the
conference's do interviews when when no
longer did I have disproportionate
leverage that if I was off on time and
how to make somebody wait and this is
all predicated because I'm disorganized
and I'm not anal and
to the details that's when I changed and
so Matt wasn't I said Matt do you want
to be my assistant I just need it I'm
starting to travel I'm starting to do
other things my my world is evolving I
need to stop being disrespectful I need
to fix this I need to figure it out and
I was I felt that I was very on schedule
able that I couldn't follow a schedule
in the same way that I didn't think that
I would ever work out and I would tell
you that having the assistant and
following a schedule and working out
have been two of the biggest confidence
builders to me to know that I'm capable
of changing because up into that point
the first 35 years of my life I just
went with whatever was easy to me which
is why I so mailed in school following a
schedule and working out make me believe
that I could have been an A student
where I used to not believe that to be
the case so that's exciting that that
excites me for the next 40 years of my
career that I'll be able to mold and do
other things while still completely
betting on my strengths but trying to
round out not round out my weaknesses in
a way that's scalable that doesn't take
this proportion amount of energy right
it's it's if you've noticed I packed it
with other human beings an assistant a
full-time trainer so like if I can use
somebody else's skills in my ecosystem
that that's that that seems interesting
so for me the time to have an assistant
was when I felt that I was disrespecting
other people it's an interesting answer
but it's the true answer statement of
the day you know I'm just looking for
I'm looking for your comments on this
show because the feedback loop has been
immensely powerful and it's giving me
ideas of how we're gonna evolve the show
in the fourth quarter also I'd love to
know what you've been up to the last
three weeks I miss you you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
[Music]